[Música]
[Aplausos]
você se lembra onde você estava ontem
e você aí do meio você se lembra semana
passada por onde você passou
você aí de trás vocês se lembram mês
passado por onde vocês andaram
esse é o tipo de pergunta que
imediatamente nos leva a refletir onde
nós estivermos fisicamente por assim
dizer de carne e osso presente e muitas
vezes a gente não pára pra pensar sobre
os nossos light sabe aquelas notas
curtidas em redes sociais
os cliques nos vários websites que nós
acessamos daquela conversa no telefone
com o atendente da nossa operadora de
celular com o gerente do nosso banco
daquele cadastro que a gente fez na
farmácia a gente do nosso cpf em troca
de um desconto ou mesmo dos vários
aplicativos que nós acessamos em nossos
smartphones aparelhos celulares ao longo
da semana ao longo do mês
ao longo da nossa vida e todas essas
situações a gente deixa para trás dados
dados pessoais que não são apenas o
nosso nome rg cpf e endereço
foto mas todos esses rastros vinculados
a nós e que nos identificam essas
migalhas de informação juntas elas vão
compor um retrato sobre quem nós somos
nossos gostos predileções
características
enfim uma fotografia bastante precisas
sobre a nossa personalidade e é com base
nisso que uma série de decisões são
tomadas a nosso respeito
esse nosso avatar esse nosso corpo
eletrônico ele nos leva para lugares que
às vezes nós nem sabemos quais mas que
de alguma forma vão impactar as nossas
vidas
ainda mais numa sociedade cada vez mais
movida
orientada por dados isso já está
acontecendo agora é só a gente olhar
para as nossas atividades do cotidiano
em que esse nosso avatar esse nosso
corpo eletrônico os dados que são
coletados sobre nós tem impactos nas
nossas vidas nos dias dias por exemplo
não é mais o gerente do seu banco que
vai aprovar ou negar o seu crédito
mas é o famoso sistema
o sistema vai processar uma série de
dados sobre você
como por exemplo a conta de luz que você
deixou de pagar a conta de água que você
pagou com atraso ou de maneira pontual
o sistema vai processar esses dados vai
calcular todas essas informações e vai
retornar o resultado
se você é um bom ou mau pagador é o
sistema que vai aprovar ou vai negar o
seu crédito e fixar a sua taxa de juros
de forma maior ou menor plano e seguro
de saúde a mesma coisa é o sistema que
vai processar uma série de dados sobre
você como do seu histórico saúde e vai
dizer o risco o seu risco de contrair
mais ou menos doenças ter mais ou menos
complicações médicas e o preço que você
vai pagar mas ser maior ou menor e mais
recentemente foi o sistema que
impossibilitou que vários brasileiros
deixassem de sacar sua aposentadoria na
boca do caixa porque porque a base de
dados do sistema
diziam que essas pessoas estavam mortas
e que elas não poderiam portanto serem
beneficiárias deste tipo de assistência
a todo momento os nossos passos nossos
rastros estão sendo constantemente
monitorados
é por isso que privacidade e proteção de
dados pessoais importa importa muito que
diz respeito à nossa identidade quem nós
somos
como nós somos vistos como nós somos
julgados proteção de dados pessoais é a
nossa própria identidade e seus dados
são você como praticamente grita a
campanha da coalizão direitos na rede
se você não controla as suas informações
pessoais
você está num trem desgovernado a minha
a sua a nossa capacidade de auto
determinação é cada vez mais calibrada
pelo uso que são feitos com os nossos
dados
por isso privacidade e proteção de dados
pessoais importa importa muito e
proteger significa estabelecer as regras
do jogo do que podem ser feitos ou não
com os nossos dados
o manual de instruções não só para
proteger a pessoa de carne e osso por
trás desses dados mas para gerar
principalmente confiança confiança entre
nós cidadãos entre organizações públicas
e privadas que se valem que fazem uso
desses dados os seus modelos de negócio
das suas atividades comerciais para a
formulação de políticas públicas
proteção de dados pessoais é uma questão
para não gerar paralisia sobre isso e se
a gente não tem essa confiança a gente
começa a encarar problemas
uma das questões do que seriam essas
regras claras as regras do jogo
um exemplo bem concreto um dos
princípios um dos direitos dos nossos
significa dados de qualidade princípio
da qualidade e agora a coisa fica mais
séria desde que o brasil aprovou uma lei
geral de proteção de dados pessoais o
que significa qualidade dos dados
significa que esse nosso avatar este
nosso corpo eletrônico ele deve ser
correto ele deve ser atualizado ele deve
ser fidedigno com a nossa personalidade
porque caso contrário se esse nosso
avatar esse nosso corpo eletrônico não
for fidedigno com quem nós realmente
somos decisões sobre nós
vão ser equivocadas vão ser erradas e
elas devem ser corretas justamente o
contrário do que está acontecendo hoje
em dia com os bloqueadores de
publicidade online quem nunca é foi
perseguido por uma publicidade
aquela publicidade que te persegue há
oito meses e como brinca o jornal
sensacionalista
ia ser presa por que perseguiu a
sapatilha a mulher durante oito meses
esse é um exemplo eloquente de como que
os nossos dados nos representam nos
projeto e se você não tem a proteção
desses dados você perde o que você perde
a confiança
a gente fica incomodado quando essa
publicidade praticamente nos assalta é
por isso que se você for olhar para
essas capas de jornais como o the
guardian new york times
e esse gráfico sozinho e vocês vão ver
que em pouco mais de um ano mais do que
duplicou a adoção de bloqueadores de
publicidade online
em pouco mais de um ano nós começamos a
instalar cada vez mais bloqueadores de
publicidades nos computadores em nossos
smartphones porque porque a troca desses
dados já não faz mais tanto sentido
a gente não vê mais tanta utilidade a
gente já não tem mais tanta confiança
nisso tudo
por isso que proteção de dados pessoais
importa importa muito se estabelecer
regras direitos e deveres de todos os
atores desse ecossistema mais uma vez
não protege só o cidadão mas traz
confiança para todo esse ecossistema
dados por exemplo de qualidade é o
pressuposto para qualquer tomada de
decisão mais eficiente
por exemplo se o banco sabe melhor o seu
consumidor
a capacidade de pagamento dos
consumidores os dados são de qualidade
ele vai dar um empréstimo que não vai
gerar endividamento para aquele
consumidor para aquele cidadão eo banco
não vai ter prejuízo mesma coisa na área
da saúde
diagnósticos mais precisos mesma coisa
na área de formulação de políticas
públicas para aqueles que realmente
precisam e não que fraudou o sistema
privacidade e proteção de dados pessoais
importa importa muito desrespeito em
última análise para que não haja um
curto circuito e nossas vidas porque
caso contrário vai haver uma ditadura
dos dados são eles que movem que
determina os rumos da
a própria sociedade por isso a
diversidade proteção de dados pessoais
importa importa muito porque com isso a
gente vai garantir que todo esse fluxo
de informação seja íntegro seja
apropriado
esse volume descomunal de dados como diz
a filósofa harry nilsson ban as nossas
legítimas expectativas na troca dessas
informações têm que ser respeitadas
o melhor exemplo disso aconteceu este
ano quando a gente viu que a desproteção
dos nossos dados pode atingir em cheio a
própria democracia o que o escândalo da
quebra de analítica mostrou foi
justamente isso
a princípio um teste dinho de
personalidade aquele que a gente faz as
redes sociais ou em aplicativos
inofensivo ingênuo
a partir desses testes foram coletados
dados sobre essas pessoas sobre os
amigos dessas pessoas o círculo social
dessas pessoas para fazer perfis
psicométricos que significa isso saber
as emoções das pessoas saber como a
mente dessas pessoas funciona essas
pessoas se tornaram mais o quê
manipuláveis vulneráveis ao que tudo
indica esses dados foi com isso que se
tornou possível que a narrativa
mensagens políticas propagandas se
tornassem mais potentes com maior
sedução poder de convencimento à
legítima expectativa dessas pessoas que
deram esses dados para esse teste de
personalidade foram frustradas por isso
proteção de dados pessoais importa
importa muito
não se engane se não houver proteção de
dados nós enquanto sociedade nós vamos
parar de produzir a matéria-prima hoje
mais importante dados e aí a gente não
vai ter liberdade para inovar e
empreender para desenvolver proteção de
dados pessoais é hoje o mais importante
e lá do nosso pacto social do nosso
contrato social
por isso a proteção de dados pessoais
importa importa muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]